ivan chagnaud propose voyage son
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de michel angot et de
l'inviter revit montage yvonne crs sont
gérés illustration sonore de nice blazer
le long de la côte pacifique costa rica
une pompe à essence bien sûr
une pompe à essence mais une route de
terre battue
et voyez les véhicules les plus courants
les rouges sont encore pleines
bravant la végétation tropicale il va
courageux le petit train à chaque arrêt
des femmes des jeunes filles fois des
fruits tropicaux principale ressource de
la région toutes les espèces se
rencontrent au marché
en longeant le pacifique on passe sans
douleur d'un cocotier costaricain
cocotiers panaméen vous voyez une langue
le faire sur l'île de thau boga à
quelques kilomètres de panama voici
l'aspect d'un village indigène
des cocotiers jusque dans le village
abondance de fleurs
pour le transport l'homme et les
pirogues remplace l'avion loto le bateau
à côté les cluses de miraflores
avec son tracteur puissant montés sur
rails
passer d'un océan à l'autre devient un
jeu
mais la vie douce ne perd jamais ses
droits sous cette latitude
végétation exubérante
est caché dans le coude d'un estuaire la
ville de las palmas construite sur
pilotis pour éviter l'inondation lors
des crues de la rivière
cette fois la transition va vous sauter
aux yeux regardez bien la végétation
équatoriale est devenu soudain grise et
desséchées ce sont les îles galapagos
une fleur
c'est à ne pas croire vite un gros plan
le manque de pluie cause de cette
aridité aviez vous déjà vu une forêt de
cactus géants
ils servent modestement de perchoirs aux
oiseaux de proie
tels des chèvres sauvages de gros sky
aux yeux bleus
et et l'iguane énorme lézard d'un mètre
vingt peureux difficile à approcher sa
peau et est une telle cuirasse qu'il ne
sent pas aux oiseaux qui se posent sur
lui pacifique il se nourrit de week-end
accrochés aux rochers
il est très voisin des reptiles du
secondaire le long de la mer il existe
une autre espèce d'iguane le marin il
vidal atteint un mètre cinquante et lui
par contre si on peut mettre le pied sur
le littoral
il n'est pas difficile de l'attraper
nous irons de surprise en surprise sur
l'équateur les galapagos sont habités
par les phoques et chose surprenante par
des pingouins
plus exactement des manchots
ils font bon voisinage avec de gros
crabes rouges
animal extraordinaire des galas sa
gauche et seulement trouvé là le
cormoran à ailes atrophiées comme le
pingouin il ne peut plus voler c'est
elle lui sert seulement de balancier
quand ils déambulent sur les rochers
cormorans gwan
e
et à côté ce prince du ciel de la
famille des fous
i tahiti de nouveau la végétation
redevient exubérante de profondes baies
-celles de littoral
telle celle de papeete au fond
sur le rivage des pirogues
elles sont le centre de la vie du
polynésien
les petites filles et coop la pirogue
les petits garçons on fabrique des
modèles réduits de pirogue est très
jeune un gamin sait manier la baguette
latérale
c'est un outil de travail cette pirogue
elle sert à la pêche les filets aussi
sont des outils de travail
il sèche dans les armes
ou dans les constructions spéciale
la maison polynésienne est très sain
tout d'entrelacs de divers palme plus
jeune polynésienne est grosse plus elle
a lieu d'être fiers personne là bas
n'hésitent à ce coureur né voici la vie
courante
que l'on soit il faut tuer pour vivre
elle a l'air d'aimer ce qu'elle fait
michel angot m'a assuré que même nanti
d'un effroyable mal de dents il était
impossible de n'être pas heureux en
polynésie dans les êtres ils sont calmes
attentif à votre bonheur
où va cette vieille chinoise assister au
départ d'un bateau
si vous ou moi avions quelques semaines
de polynésie nous saurions que c'est
toujours une fête la guitare importés
par les blancs a remplacé le pipeau de
rougeau
on l'emploie aussi lors des danses à
pouvoir pouvoir comme moi et carmela
médical où toutes les tempêtes open 3
les fouilles à tout un programme
tara amour et caro elle a payé cas où
l'on occupé d'envoi les tempes et robert
collet bouyaka polaha herria
et là là là des phillies et la vraie ou
là chaque geste a un sens défini et
précis
et il est toujours un plaisantin autre
cage où le fait que départ d'un avion
plutôt d'un hydravion
la coutume veut que lorsque l'on quitte
la rive l'on rejette allons les
couronnes reçu à l'exception d'une qui
servira à interroger le destin
jeter dans la passe du récif si elle
revient dans la baie de papeete les
dieux à cet instant décidé votre retour